macht euch schon mal auf das sehr
gefasst denn ich reagiere auf hilf mir
hashtag famous süchtig nach likes das
ist der titel der heutigen episode meine
lieben freunde und bevor wir uns das
ganze anschauen würde ich sagen werfen
wir wieder einen blick in die kommentare
im ersten satz schon mehr hashtags als
ich jemals posten werde ring spiel bei
jedem hashtag wird ein schott getrunken
das hashtag nervt tierisch wer zum
teufel redet in hashtags sie hat zu
selten hashtag gesagt finde ich immer
wenn sie was von hashtag labert werde
ich aggressiv
ich glaube das wird eine hashtag krise
folge
[Musik]
vier sekunden
sekunden geht die folge und wir sind
jetzt schon
richtig nicht auf lukas kann nur besser
werden ich habe mich gerade den hashtag
urlaub heftig mallorca
[Musik]
als perfektes wetter das blaue meer im
hintergrund herrscht extremes
[Musik]
hier steckt freilich natürlich um die
welt ich hoffe euch nicht meine besten
cera wieder heißt die
warum passen einfach perfekt was mir
dass ich will meinen video für meine
follower
also auf die uhr geschaut muss dann bis
zum tönen
doch wirklich zum döner laden
arbeitet sie dort oder oder waren
mussten gehen das nur noch einmal ich
bin noch weiterentwickelt ist so da
braucht es nicht mehr so ach so ja was
hast du dir dabei vorgestellt das ist
mallorca
blöde kuh
ich führte die sarafina spiegel so
sollen
diese nicht auf malle wir sind wie
berlin-neukölln ist das wetter
voneinander entfernen können zwei
regionen mit
sand wollte mir gerade noch sagen nicht
also jedoch verletzt und hashtag
muscheln
stück strand vorstand der hashtag
strandliege hashtag beach
tech hotel hashtag scheiße er licht
sorgt der ist nämlich nicht
locker stofftier sarafina du bist jetzt
schon also hashtag best buddy wofür wir
so so sind jetzt
klar
da stand gestern in der zeitung was ich
wirklich real talk sagen muss ist dass
die seraphina eine richtig gute
schauspielerische leistung bisher und
tag legt
serafina ist 18 und ständig online ihr
großer traum in fluren werden und soll
das handy war dann aber auch leider
nicht mal an
so wird das dann glaube ich nichts mit
der sec
[Musik]
also ich hab diamant nägel
rom ist in der drag drop und ein outfit
kaufen müssen die
fashionistas in einer kauft keine gianna
ein moment
also meines wissens nach kaufen kim
kardashian und kylie jenner im
klartext wir gesehen dass einfach so
perfekt ist wie entgeistert doch so viel
hass zwischen den wehren wie du
[Musik]
außerdem war das auch mal zum friseur
james
einfach 200 euro verhängt nur heute her
dass krass
200 euro also das ist echt ein knapper
da würde ich direkt zuschlagen wenn ich
200 euro für friseur ausgeben würde
könnte ich für die summe zehn mal
hingehen
vielleicht mache ich was falsch
verdanken die tipps werde ich
hoffentlich aus
[Musik]
zehn minuten später
séraphine nutzt jede gelegenheit um sich
im netz zu präsentieren
[Musik]
die fotos sind einfach perfekt
also zeitgleich das wort gesagt haben
was machst du wieder mit der technik
marketing
[Musik]
alter macht schön ab
jetzt höre auf ihr chef scheint wirklich
einen langen geduld haben zu haben
erst puma
bestellt
wir müssen zu hashtag seraphina an jetzt
mal eben nur noch die gurkenmaske von
tanz das ist einfach perfekt also garten
ganz kurz serafin als kompletter
wortschatz besteht aus einfach perfekt
und hashtag
mit meinen perfekten trikot werdet ihr
auch alle so gut aussehen wie ich heftig
safinas palace
hashtag seraphina spelles
age
wir brechen das setzt an der stelle ab
mit denen backpfeifen denn wir brechen
auf das video und der stelle jetzt ab
meine lieben freunde ich habe mir zwar
erst ein drittel des kompletten videos
angeschaut allerdings geht es einfach
nicht weiter mehr geht einfach gerade
nicht wenn euch meine reaktion auf diese
hilfe episode allerdings gefallen hat
dann lass genen einen daumen hoch und
ein video hat schreibt im auto in die
kommentare ob ich eventuell auch auf den
rest des videos reagieren soll ich meine
wir haben jetzt auf fünf von 17 minuten
reagiert wenn er bock drauf hat man das
nicht verpassen wollte abonniert gern
mal einen kanal unter dem video ich weiß
dass ganz viele noch kein abonnent von
einem kanal sind die sich dieses video
hier gerade anschauen nämlich mehr als
die hälfte was macht ihr richtig im
leben
[Musik]